le quéau scientifiquement l'acte i need
ya le kiwi originaires de chine est
planté chez nous dans les années 70 la
france fait le pari fou de développer
une filière
il était alors les premiers en europe
nous pensions remplacer la culture du
péché et notre d'arbres fruitiers
on a essayé de mésaventure ici dans le
gard mais aussi dans les
pyrénées-orientales en corse et en
bretagne
le kiwi s'implante en france mais pour
le consommateur c'est un fruit exotique
comme l'ananas ou l'avocat il se destine
essentiellement à l'étranger 95% de la
production est exportée suède belgique
allemagne et la france maître dans l'art
du kiwi jusqu'à ce qu'un voisin s'en
mêle l'italie se lance dans les années
80 et devient leader du marché européen
sa production en 1990 300 mille tonnes
c'est six fois plus que chez nous un
concurrent agressif avec une saison plus
étendue de quoi agacer des kiwis
culteurs français 150 tonnes de fruits
des vergers dans la rue et 10 milliards
de centimes de pertes sèches sans
compter qu l'italie absorbe l'essentiel
des subventions européennes et que le
kiwi italien coûte moins cher
aujourd'hui on en est à zéro franc le
kilo ou moins quelque chose pour le
producteur probablement moins 50
centimes - francs pour certaines
stations
une des solutions depuis les années 90
jouer la carte de la qualité
le kiwi de l'adour par exemple cultivés
dans le sud ouest
il est le seul à avoir obtenu un label
rouge en 1992 puis une indication
géographique protégée en 2009
cette identification géographique tant
qu'entraîneur à pic
en plus de notre label rouge ça va
asseoir un territoire et donc on pourra
se défendre au mieux par rapport par
exemple aux kiwis italiens qui sont
notre principale
dans l'adour et ailleurs la france
produit soit 103 mille tonnes chaque
année
c'est moins que la grèce est moins que
l'italie
toujours leader du marché européen
[Musique]